india descended into coba 19 chaos this
is a bbc story
in january february the national number
of daily cases fell under 20 000
from peaks of 90 000 in september of
last year prime minister
modi declared covet beaten and all
places are public gathering open and
soon people were not adhering to the
kovitz safety protocols
things and thanks in part to confused
messaging from the top
while modi asked people to wear masks
and follow social dissonance public
messages
he addressed large unmasked crowds
during his election campaigns in five
states a number of his ministers
were also seen addressing large public
gatherings without wearing a mask the
kuma
the the kumbala a hindu festival which
attracts millions was also allowed to go
ahead
anyways this goes into the number of
india initially wanted 300 million
people
vaccinated by july but it seems the
government did not do enough planning to
secure vaccine supply to run the program
on top of it it has opened a vaccination
for adults without securing vaccine
supply so here's a number we're looking
at
so far only 26 million people in india
have been fully vaccinated out of a
population of 1.4 billion
and about 124 million have received a
single dose india has millions more
doses on
doses on order but still far short of
what it actually needs this is what they
need the federal government needs 615
million doses
of vaccinate to vaccinate everyone above
the age of 45 by 440 million
people there are 622 million people ages
18 to 44
and 1.2 million doses doses are required
to vaccinate them
catastrophic situation going on there
here's what china did they have pop-up
crematoriums that's a
by the way you're talking about 400 000
people a day a day
a day right now yeah by the way the
united states has fallen
down on this maintaining india
as a key ally means that we should have
been
sharing hey this is how you distribute
vaccines proactive with them
i mean we we have i mean we've done it
we've distributed
we've done it and we've done it
successfully it was planned beautifully
we have people in our military
who can be advising the leadership in
india and and what have we done it's
like there's mr magoo in the white house
i didn't say that
chinese government authorities deleted
post mock in india's i'm going to read
this and i'm going to turn it over to
adam chinese government authorities the
leader post mocking india's kobe 19
tragedy after receiving backlash this is
another business
insider story images on social media by
the way can you try to find this image
of the pictures posted on the article
images on social media posted by two
chinese official
accounts are drawn rebuke for appearing
to mock india's catastrophic battle with
covet 19
an account link to the ruling communist
party posted
an image on saturday comparing this
country's successful launch of his
taiyan module
into space with lines of burning
cremation priors in india the image
posted by government central
political legal affairs commissions on
weibo account was captioned
china lighting of fire versus india
lighting a fire it carried a hashtag
noting india's coronaviruses
cases top 400 000 a day multiple other
government accounts run by the police
and law enforcement agency shared an
image two
posts were deleted after many chinese
weibo users expressed
anger at the insensitivity expressed
what are you thinking well i think
china learned a few things from dealing
with donald trump uh you know how to do
a trade war
uh and how to be a troll so this uh
the this response right here is very
trumpy
of china to basically troll a very
sad situation that's going on india and
then the only reference that i have for
india
is that they were actually doing a great
job beating the coronavirus and then
they pulled it to sean jackson
and basically spiked the ball to one
yard line
and the game has completely changed and
now they're
the poster child for basically taking
your eye off the ball when it comes to
covet
tom this goes back to what danielle said
earlier about an hour ago we were
talking about
and worse the dependency on vaccine
manufacturing right now
and who would be happy to sit on this
side of the line
and let india twist for a little while
yep china
absolutely this is this is this is th
this was not a dig china's love industry
this was a dig to the united states that
post was screw you
and i'm not going to help yeah that's
exactly why why don't you turn to your
friends
in the white house and see what they're
going to do for you
well what happened if india says china
we need your help that's the only person
that can give them one point two million
dollars
exactly right did they go begging saying
hey please help us
i mean the magnitude of this tragedy is
hard to i mean
how does china react does china say no
how do you wrap your head around 400 000
people a day
how does china respond to it though if
they come out and publicly ask yeah
oh i think that puts china in a really
tough spot so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye